okay cool you think be sorry if you
think sound of that yeah rhian it's
about that we got disconnected for a
brief moment my apologies can you stay
on the Yunel one cool please with the
common sir what's up guys you know rare
the man can you put your laptop here
we're gonna block your face so angry
here is the comments we got Andrew here
with us awesome Gotham ER to give us 10
likes what's up here for the subs a
minha 14 99 how many people are tuning
already 20 viewers already that's like
double than what we had yesterday that
is awesome that is awesome thank you
guys for tuning it so let me just make
sure we're live on youtube as well give
me one second porfavor this is us mm-hmm
okay we're good if she does sound good
right now sort of thing alright so we're
on YouTube we got all right we got a
good amount of people and let's kick off
this movie talk so we got and you're
with us from movie source channel you
got John with us from Blum house and the
real rejects and i'm here today
representing the schmoes now so let's
get into this guy's we got some movie
news you want to cover John last thing I
forgot to do can you open up those
articles because I forgot there on that
laptop over there yeah no problem I'm
just gonna open the same one day wells
ampe just asked us a question of well
John opens up Andrea I can answer this
case they want to know what movies were
looking forward to the most next year
you guys here
okay by the way so I make sure y'all can
hear us all right the laptops a little
far off the top of my head obviously
Star Wars Episode a of course I'm gonna
see that storyline continue from the
last movie coming out next year yeah
what answers listing why we're about to
be in store with his team's uh sorry I'm
thinking so far ahead but also i'd say
i'm looking forward to the Justice
League see what happens there I want to
see a thor ragnarok obviously a
spider-man homecoming still hasn't
listed my movie what's your movie Logan
Logan that looks really good to hook
into my number one movie that I'm so
looking forward to next year I think
it's gonna be the best x-men movie we've
ever had you know what I heard I heard
that I mean John I talked about this a
while ago they played 40 minutes of that
at Fox that crazy that's a lot of why
would you want to be 40 minutes like
magical show them the whole [ __ ]
point i would not wanted to see 40
minutes i can and it just sounds loud
that sounds silly that sounds really
silly okay deep p what's going on i am a
NOAA flores george h will answer a
couple more questions and we'll go into
the talk we want to do they couldn't see
the questions join I know I am why are
you signing it to you now because we
can't keep page we can't look at can you
sign with your Twitter because if you
sign it with the real rejects we're
going to be going to this computer there
we go all right we're still alive right
okay cool george h do you think the
marble TV characters will be in the
Avengers infinity war marvel h uh no I
hope they're not I hope that they put
them in there there at least in the
second one whatever that one's going to
be called I don't mind seeing them in
the movie if it's like just for a quick
second like you know maybe Thanos is
causing some kind of mayhem and then you
just see a quick shot of them but I mean
we've already got so many characters in
the movie so obviously I want to it'd be
cool to see on screen but I just don't
know if they have
the time of the amount of characters
enough to do it but it'd be cool for
like a little cameo sequence I'd be cool
for that that'd be cool for that too I
just feel like the film's already gonna
have like the biggest obstacle in the
world that I think overstuffing to a TV
care and the TV world is so different
from the movies to like every one of the
movies is is there's a similar tone
between all of them that allows them all
the link up and like a crossover though
and the show's likewise for their change
or oh I feel like yeah the shows are
hard are ya the shows are very r-rated
some dirty but the Flies and the gore
isn't seen that Oh keep in the first
season with that guy door for sure
absolutely Oh real quick guys run DJ
Rudd TV he donated 30 bars run DJ run TV
you make me feel full of Glee cuz that
rhymes with TV just like Greggy like the
UH like the show he's black a lot of one
the black Mansell you know donates like
yo I've been through a lot and the fact
that they're willing to give to me a
struggling Filipino Italian man that's
beautiful that says something Barack
Obama was the greatest all rights I
assure shouldn't took pains right out of
them hi I'm Noah donated 15 bars Noah
thank you know you are new who also
struggled Noah from Noah's Ark his last
name was arc mr. arc mr. czar and Andrew
drew up super Catholic and yellow he
well no wait you're actually Juba can
Jewish people know that I Noah right did
this video shoot I never from them not
the most religious guys are we grew up
Catholic and no over here you know was
Jewish not just like your people nice go
now up and just no no I just learned
what a live stream is circumstantial
Peters bars means something I forget
what they mean but they equivalent to
something that means awesomeness for us
just you know different measures with
rhymes with them and let's go in one
more question over here one more tuition
what first off deep deep p haha get it
the things deep p maybe
indian no no it's like DP like double
penetration that deserves some bars DPA
said that in um Noah Flores if you're a
wannabe writer welcome to our world
where everyone's a wannabe writer CDP
said haha he gets the joke alia asked
what's up and okay okay cool cool
alright so first story that will talk
about before we get into the mainland we
will talk about gotham city sirens in a
second first one I want to talk about is
how Winter Soldier and Harley Quinn are
finally crossing over in a movie I am so
excited and it's gonna be based around
the Tonya Harding biopic whoo now it was
four years old when this incident
happened John was eight he's four years
older than me but we're in the same
grade because I'm smarter than him yeah
andrew is closing seven years old and so
he was around and awake when all this
was going on yeah uh what's the time
heart incident you seem to get very
passionate and upset when you found out
uh well let's get the red the reason I
found out about this is the amazing
movie blades of glory time o'farrell and
John John heater yes sir Nancy Kerrigan
is actually in the film and I remember
seeing her in the film and just hearing
that she was an amazing you know figure
skater so I wanted to you know read up
on her by op her bio and so I saw what
you know when adma Tonya Harding and
always mini like just really resent her
and I hate Tonya Harding's gud so I felt
so bad for Nancy Kerrigan's to so this
is a it's interesting that they're gonna
make a film but I mean I thought one day
they would but i love the choices who
like you said Winter Soldier and
harlequin I think she's really like if
anyone can play a piece of [ __ ] badass
it's it's I mean not a bad ass but it
makes plays a badass which was hardly
but a piece of [ __ ] at least I mean she
was still in the Olympics so she was a
good figure skater now I mean wait did
you clarified like what she did exactly
I didn't go into what you did but just I
don't want to spoil the movie but I just
fly and spoil history yeah well yeah
what happened was time
arting and her ex-husband I don't know
if it was her ex at the time they
basically set up a way to injure it was
a other person Nancy Kerrigan and injure
her so she couldn't compete against her
because she was the number one threat
ruin her career and you know honestly
like I I wonder what approach that movie
will take will it be like we sympathize
for Tonya Harding is the movie gonna go
out of its way to really go go she's a
[ __ ] like what what approach will they
take with it regardless though seen
Sebastian Shaw oh and uh fashion Stan
Stan who Sean nobody that's no bueno
Sebastian Shaw x-men first class Kevin
Bacon's character Oh see moresee trivial
modems just connected right into Kevin
Bacon's perfect real quick aust agrees
Kevin Bacon what's the black Brian it's
his birthday today guys a big birthday
happy birthday man okay so yeah Chris
Evans sets star in this there's another
story here before you're going to gotham
city sirens chris evans is set to star
in the jekyll movie for director ruben
fleischer Flay sure he's a director do
you also direct anchor spot yeah and 30
minutes or less yeah any goes all events
Eisenberg zombieland was like his last
good I loved zombieland it's like the
one film that everybody agrees on the we
that we know I gangster squad sucks in
30 minutes or less I was one of the few
people who thought that movie was pretty
funny but I rented that movie on I don't
think if i pay to watch it i would have
enjoyed it as much 30 minutes or less
seems like one of those comedies that
like every but you like everybody in it
and so you'll at least enjoy it for that
right yeah i think the biggest news
though with Jekyll is they made it clear
that it's not connected to the new
universal monster universe yeah so I
mean that's going to be as you know it's
a remake of the BBC show yeah yeah which
I have not seen yeah and I'm not saying
everything has to be connected but I
mean I would have been a little more
intrigued had I known it's connected but
I mean I guess it's cool if they're not
going to
worried about being a franchise and they
can worry about their own thing exactly
yeah that's a great point I mean for me
what excites me is chris evans i feel is
has a lot more range than what the
masses know him to have you know like
the biggest roles he has had hard human
torch and Captain America but he's done
a lot of other roles like a lot of indie
films rate is a great job he's even like
I think he's like the ice ice truck
killer or the froth frosty man there was
something like that is this started on
another team movie come on yeah there
you got that one too cellular you guys
see that one wanted to takes on Jason
Statham um but yeah cellular yeah yeah
so I just said no big Chris was there
was one is the Iceman snowpiercer which
is supposed to do is hurt and I feel
like you know that to play a role like
Jeff I don't know how they're gonna do I
don't know they're gonna like have a
goal cgi when he becomes which ones that
evil one gesture hide hi sir hi okay
it's dr. Jekyll mr. all right when mr.
Hyde I don't know if we're gonna head
like CGI him or something I would love
it if he really does get a chance to
showcase two very different characters
in this movie because I think he
deserves a chance to really showcase his
range and this seems like the kind of
movie where he can showcases range and
people will tune in to go watch it as
well so they're there they're remaking
this show as just a move I'm pretty sure
that's what they're doing they do that
sometimes a BBC shows a remake them as I
know they did that with edge of darkness
something else really I don't know those
edge of dartmoor zvc miniseries so yeah
oh whoa I hope so I feel like that
that's the appeal of playing a character
like that like you gotta give that after
a chance to play two different sides of
a coin because dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde is
like I got mention us a gift for an
actor to be able to play yeah because
it's a chance to really showcase like
much more of your talents you can play
two characters and one that's awesome
and I would love to I hope your sevens
rocks that role I hoping i hope it does
perform well and I really helped Rubin
flow fleshlight does a great job with
hun why
yeah I want to point out one night and
one night miss 5 6 190 don't need a
hundred twenty bars oh thank you so much
do if you're trying to get a picture of
my nipples you just got a message me on
instagram hey if you're doing too much
work my friend if we can I missed if we
get 150 more bars you'll just show them
right now oh no two hundred bars will
show my nipples two hundred bars it's
all it takes to get me to show some nips
guys it's cheap this is what I do you
now for movie talk stripteasing yeah I
think I'm a great strip I think Andrew
can dance really well doesn't just have
that personality a little body dancer
you look like very graceful they stuff
oh my goosh aid in dirty dancing stole
their votes from me that's what oh [ __ ]
the first one-man show brown donated two
thousand Sam oh wow that is so kind
three thousand bar thank you so much
that's very kind thank you 00 10 it's
even got a little bit of a chill you
give them an inch away I look kind of
tone from this form or I'm sitting and
looking at this screen I look a lot more
toned than if I was really up close to
you guys what this is for you Joe Brown
this is for you looking at your body I
still don't know how you're not in a
Marvel movie or DC move its that's how I
feel every time I shower cause like the
first time I saw Chris Pratt take it
sure oh dude this is all for Joe Brown
you guys don't look I'm sorry so
everyone turn off their computer this is
just for Joe Brown there you go but I'm
in our American Pie moment and drew I
think you any more subs a new channel
dope channel don't review happy aviary
gave you some love ex but it should they
reboot Trevor's or maximum overdrive the
thing is I really wish you could reboot
Maximum Overdrive now because I'm just
do badass I don't I don't think now's
the time hey I know people on you
because we like to swing this to know CJ
mr.
no we like your whoa so much you so many
comments are on the YouTube one though
oh man some is reps you a trick f sub
hashtag free the nipple dude I I think
there's I don't know if there's a lotta
Joshua I am not fat I am pleasantly
obese [ __ ] if some of Jesus guys did
you see him all online yet I haven't I
know you told me I gotta see it I know
John can you quickly tell him he thought
oh lala land oh you guys got to see you
guys got to hear this I what do you mean
can you gonna make me review it like if
you guys just give a quick opinion a lot
to me of all lands the best minute we
have seen all year yeah I really love
them I had a great time watching and I
went alone I like I have my own sort of
treat day and like there's so much heart
and joy in a doobie and and you know
like at least right now before the
inevitable backlash machine sets in like
it is a perfect meld of classic you know
jazz musical with a modern movie that is
just a terrific you just made my soul
happy so you guys are saying I should
avoid it okay yeah don't watch it
alright man washing it know how like
some people try killing themselves after
avatar you will definitely kill yourself
because that movie is the best thing
ever and you'll realize that your life
will never amount to anything as good as
that movie it's it's playing in New York
and LA right now it's on five screens
like it'll go wider I think yeah a few
weeks at least hey YouTube folks just
want to let you know we are now looking
at your comments Jose Luis keeps asking
are you reading YouTube yes yes Jose
people just keep putting in the same
questions was just smart because you
know sometimes you're a lot of these
comments come in yeah a lot of people
are talking about being fat right now
that's awesome um great against me and
Ricky what's up dawg all right you two
people ok I was selling out yeah Leo
what's up Matt subway far my favorite
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle Boston
beauty became a fan it is very
the trailer I wouldn't normally want to
hear Boston I go you [ __ ] [ __ ]
but now hard it's a great move number
one fan good night mist oh my gosh are
we excited about the new parts the
Caribbean movie guys uh not really nice
is for you specialist for United I
checked I want to be excited I checked
out us I have world's end I I was done
at that point the first movie is amazing
armpit hair to amp up the sexual tension
oh yeah I'm just eating a lot e oh yeah
oh you see that you see that Andrew you
see that see it it's in my pretty manly
for nine minutes long but it's also for
you I'm here to stare at you two rich
beep it's covered hey didn't you guys
ever watched I lethal weapon show
Christopher anyone wants to know now I
didn't but I heard some people say they
actually enjoyed it but I didn't yeah i
haven't seen it it's just it's not
everyone I'm so obsessed with the movies
I just didn't know how to feel about
seeing the show so it's very skeptical
everyone keeps telling me it's a good
show and I just I I don't know me I feel
like it's the one thing out there where
my ego is so up against that [ __ ] like
man I'm just not even allowing myself to
even try to check this out I just don't
even want any of that imagery in my head
I feel there's only one Martin Riggs and
Roger Murtaugh I could be very wrong
about this but I feel like the lethal
weapon shows is probably like a pretty
good crime procedural and not much more
than that I I don't know hey nightmare
since he donated so much since you're
the number one fan on you now we will
answer your question are you excited for
underworld blood wars since you donate
so much will give you an answer no not
really i might even skip the movie are
you any of you guys have ever seen one
in the world so I'm definitely very
excited to see it I stopped at three I
stopped halfway through three and I was
like I'm done with this is boring but
I'm late just just to see what happened
after so I like this Kate Beckinsale
yeah she's in this one I don't know like
we get to the point now we're like when
movie like
the world like a new underworld comes
around I'm like hey franchises are
getting to the point where they'll
randomly get good again and like
everything is getting recall tivated so
yeah I check in now and seeing but I'm
not rushing out to see it mom yeah but
i'm not a huge underworld um no I mean
you've got a point like the fast series
has gotten better as time goes on the
mission of possible series gets better
as time goes on I lack look like
underworld and resident evil or kind of
similar like they're totally different
but they're kind of similar joe anderson
is kurt cobain great call uh yeah they
are kind of similar they feel like the
same video game hey guys it's not
resident evil Angela kelechi on the
YouTube said you guys are my favorite
react channel oh that we beat you yeah
we saw you and resources all about
reaction needs to stop I know buzz were
the best quit react with Ryder Rex
behind you know I was talking with this
a lady subscriber yesterday who was
telling me how she's really uh she lives
in Florida name's crystal hey crystal
she's just telling me how she loves
watching the reactions because she
doesn't know a lot of people who nerd
out over movies and shows the way how we
do when we do reactions that allows her
to feel like she's you know with a
friend who's nerding out with her and
that made me feel special cuz in
California you meet everyone and
everyone any trailer i watch everyone i
know is [ __ ] seen it already but in
like apparently in other parts of
America though but they're not
everyone's so into movies like they are
you're in LA so that that's when they
really get the chance to see you know
the people with love and Ricky the
shoemaker you better not leave me you
make the best shoes by fedoras jeepers
creepers I don't know where there's an
emission actors they're gonna stop
getting made or not I've heard for so
long they're gonna make that live in
trying but I think Victor selves is not
a good standing anymore with society
yeah I think they're like we're gonna
great out no people were two fists we're
not gonna cream like this
reg V says he's here to stare at Jerry
Oh Jerry is someone I love staring at
you know why because his name's not even
Jerry it's John but I look at you as a
Jerry I've played it Jerry we've all
played Jerry's duvall play jury I mean
in various men just don't you ever been
in Jason you're Jewish injuries James
deny me many times connections
automatically to ass through there
thanks for being judgmental man it's not
being judgmental I'm saying you get a
privilege like the way how us Catholics
can go to church Olive Garden others no
good in like that but it's for Italian
Roman Catholics that's that's you'll
understand it more it's like watching
it's like watching the wet hot American
TV show it's like you'll get it more if
you saw the movie you can still come
alright guys we're delay this long
enough let's talk about the gotham city
sirens move yeah okay and your kick
start us off what is Jotham city sirens
give us a little brief breakdown well we
got a Harley Quinn margot robbie is
coming back we got Catwoman's going to
be in the movie in poison ivy we got
David air from the director of Suicide
Squad is coming back to direct this film
and you know I don't know too much about
the gotham city sirens storyline I just
know obviously you know from being a
humongous fan of the batman animated
series as a kid I'm with some of my
favorite episodes were when Harley Quinn
and and poison ivy teamed up so from
that aspect i'm looking very very much
forward to this you know one I just I
like suicide squad there were a lot of
parts in it that were a jumbled mess
though so I don't know how I feel about
David Ayer doing it just from the way
the DC Universe has been going the way
how warner brothers have been meddling
and in these movies affairs so the
concept in the idea sounds really cool
and I love all three of these characters
but I'm kind of worried like is Catwoman
gonna have me out tattoo to her forehead
and poison ivy gonna have like the Leafs
tattoos and stuff like that because i
mean i don't know like suicide squad
again like I said they were portions and
parts i did life but i don't know how to
feel about David Ayer directing this so
John what do you think I'm at the point
now I realize this this afternoon we're
like now whatever
DC announces I'm in the place runs kinda
gonna throw up my hands and giggle a
little [ __ ] what you're gonna do cuz
like now there are no rules anymore
especially with light as weird and
disjointed as everything ceramic Batman
vs Superman and then Suicide Squad was
like at this point I'm mostly just along
for the ride and like amused until
something happens yeah it's like David
Ayer again I I think he's he's made more
competent films enough to the point that
Suicide Squad doesn't like make it be
completely doubt his ability to direct
film ever again I'm curious as to how
that'll go over when he's doing it for
DC again cuz I don't know what their
deal is but I don't I'm not like David
Ayer yet cuz like Suicide Squad seems
like it it's yeah I'll see what happens
next guys I think these you're crazy I
think Suicide Squad couldn't have been
any better at all I think it's suicide
squad was the benchmark for future we
can be nominated for Best Picture oh no
it's a suicide squads a big pile of [ __ ]
were you joking I was joking won't money
called sarcasm got that was challenger
Leto's Joker there and I did it ha now
that Joker lot would have been cool he
just did it like that um I just feel
like they're [ __ ] up Batman's rogue
agreed so much like why are you showing
us Batman toll road gallery before i
even have damage we towed itself with
any of them there were so late there you
know you've already given us dead I know
Deadshot isn't like other DC stuff too
but you got dead shot already to Harley
Quinn in there you got killer across
these people who are known to be that
the Joker and now you're putting poison
ivy cap open up there before putting
them in a like establishing the Batman
dynamics and stuff like oh we're just
slightly hint a little more that they
that Batman was a part of their past I
think I think it's spoiling Batman I
think it's more
like a big fun of what we could have her
Batsy dude I do I you know I urgently
rushing it I feel like deep why are they
still rushing it I'm sorry John but why
is it so question about DC that becomes
clear to me and I don't know what makes
it this way but they I almost feel like
their company whose film division is run
by a comic book reading eleven-year-old
because like that's what the attention
span seems like there doesn't seem to be
any foresight is X I my son yeah when
something works they're just like oh
yeah we'll just make that when people
love that like hey suicides what's
really messy movie that's all over the
place [ __ ] up but a lot of people
don't like but let's do the other really
cool sounding from when we've already
proved to the candy DC mail the DC EU
has become exactly a movie studio
franchise like I love that Marvel's like
while they have things that are very
much like okay this is like the Marvel
beachy we all know a Marvel beachy now
for special for their origin movies but
they still go out of their way to tend
to fans and I know how to still give us
good movies what DC is doing is not
listening to what anyone saying anything
they're not listening to a single person
who is complaining they just go but it's
making money so let's just keep doing
more of that well DC talks on both sides
of their mouth on that's the problem is
they can't stand around and go normally
the fans the fans this movie like the
appetizer my hands of fans it's not
about the fact but this is what people
are saying and now we gotta reshoot on
movies to make them more fun like taking
that were it they were outwardly denying
and applied to our movie and for me like
look I love these characters but I want
I want other people to love him to
people who don't cater to DC characters
you know people who don't know these
characters I want them to go into these
movies go I never really I mean I know
we had poison ivy back in [ __ ] Batman
and Robin but that was amazing it's yeah
but I mean like the I know we've seen
some of these characters and pass films
but a lot of the movie going audience
nowadays they I'm not invested in these
care
now you're just throwing them in films
and saying all Batman fought them in the
past and now here's a new story line so
I'm with you from that perspective it be
nice to where they could be in a solo
Batman movie and then we expand the
story and then do it but like their solo
movies up yeah there's the thing I don't
think there's no other way like I think
there is a different way to do it than
what Marvel does but the thing that
skeeves me now about DC is that I know
the trailers gonna look amazing I just
know they they have great ad team who
could sell just about anything and you
know those trailers all come out looking
different which is a telltale sign but
the thing is what I realize about Marvel
is even though there are complaints
about their structure and their plan
when Marvel lays out a plan you kind of
get what they're talking about and DC
seems like they have no plan whatsoever
and especially with the shaky as all of
their movies post Dark Knight Rises and
Ben I just have no trust that they know
that they have an idea yeah I seem to
kind of do whatever they want when
people say so and they don't look very
hard to the quality basically what John
is saying wait for the extended edition
because i want to know these people like
now more than ever it's crucial for me
if i'm going to care about a DC Universe
movie ever again is for them to go
here's our plan here's why we're going
to do these in this order here's what
it's leading to because right now it
seems like they're just gonna hurry to
get to jump yeah hey real quick I'm
going to continue this talk but
Stephanie on and Danielle d became fans
oh I mean I know both of these women
thank you I've met both of these women
they're wonderful performers they really
know how to work a pole I'm kidding
ladies thank you so much i would be kind
and respectful to you for the remainder
of this broadcast um hey Stephanie so
yeah okay Nick Nick sit forever
em you try fan right Big Daddy's
officially not a fan anymore oh um
anyway okay I just what really upsets me
about this this move if they got David
ater back why why David aired he already
proved that like most people don't
consider suicide squad that good of
movie and David ater I thought greatly
fumbled the ball its suicide squad and I
just don't see how okay yeah let's clash
more let's go female suicide squad like
movie with David aider and I just feel
like that's like getting zack snyder to
direct Justice League after Batman V
Superman but here's the thing here's the
thing ADC does that and be again we
don't this is the problem with these
movies there's so many news reports
there's so much speculation we don't
know what happened truly with either vvs
or suicide squad and again we have these
guys past movies to go off of and so
David era returning is a weird concept
to me because they don't like the
combination of David Ayer DC yeah but
again i don't think that suicide squad
was such a David a or peace and likely
even publicized how little time and
write it and all the reasoning they did
I'm not optimistic but I'm not like why
the [ __ ] would you get this guy I'm
surprised that they did but I think if
they back off maybe he could do a good
job this time you know uh yeah they're
not gonna do that they're not gonna do
that but they're not gonna because you
know what they're gonna say to David
Ayer we have if we didn't back off
suicides go up wouldn't have made so
much money i'm looking through like
those those BBS at least in Suicide
Squad had money built into them and the
thing is like we have Wonder Woman and
justice Lee and Aquaman to find some of
this out and I'm a little worried for
Wonder Woman because of that letter and
just because of the timeline and because
of everything has led up to that yeah
and I'm concerned for justice league
because that trailer is awesome you know
and that's I'm a little afraid of that
but John's actually know that every
great trailer
Will's to a great movie yeah yeah it's
the rule did you try that batman forever
trailer thing I said she liked that
really proved there's this new Batman
Forever trip not new but it's a batman
forever trailer with tron legacy music
on it and I'm not the biggest fan of
that movie but the way you see the
trailer cut it looks like a dark epic
story that's being told the best mashup
trailer I ever saw was dark knight
inception style hi I was the best one I
ever saw let's look at some comments
again real fast or we move on to the
next story should we check on YouTube
yeah let's look on youtube we're looking
on YouTube now oh this is YouTube sorry
yes yes Anthony pennies is happy
birthday to me thank you I am 46 years
old as of today um hey where's guru guy
Dan you guys know where's who rude guy
oh the country oh girl I Hannah hello
where's her recorder robot isn't that
where funny / this from lose it yeah
he's really he's German the South
America ah yes in German uh that uh real
quick wait so he keeps asking Oh one
question Oh somebody comes asking if
they if you think universe and fast the
furious after the hazel so Universal end
fastener I will take a question from the
audience for the universal and fastened
and fasten the Furious oops after eight
no no I don't think they should end
fastener it is anymore I i agree with
andrew i say milk it for as long as you
can't dwayne johnson it's gonna be
working out for the next five years for
sure and as long as he's working out
we'll get more Fast and Furious movies
Vin Diesel can do his own group spin-off
that's what I'm thinking Groot and
Dominic's reto together ndir Jaya Jaya I
would watch the answer the question as
long as they keep grossing seven hundred
million dollars and above they're gonna
keep making them so yeah we see fast and
furious says the one franchise it's
kinda like down to to a point where I'm
like all right this is one of those
money-making machine movie
is that I'm like I'm okay with because I
know what it what they know what it is
yeah they know how to make it fun but
still badass and stuff like they know
that line yeah that's true that's true I
you ridden horses tom Rick versus dawn
would have been great and then what's
another well you can't cross over fast
and furious now with Mad Max I love
jockey John and I came up with our
crossover Mad Max furious road yeah
remember that mm-hmm I had you're just
as excited about it as other fast max
I'm curious row it's like oh yes I mags
you did that was a good idea this is
cousin played by Paul Walker's brother
um anyway yeah okay so the other DC
story that came out of walk a little
while ago was Patrick Wilson is going to
be the Aquaman one of the Aquaman
villains or maybe the main one which is
cool because Zack Snyder is producing
that one Zack Snyder has worked with
Patrick Wilson before and James Wan has
worked at Patrick Wilson like what four
times now yeah this would be the fifth
time they're working together that
that's a great that's a great addition
great addition hey remember Daniel DS
question she's the first female and
Stephanie asked favorite horror movie
remember those two questions um I got to
be respectful except so adjure tell us
who's James Wan playing in the new
Aquaman jim james wan de sousa good I
everyone's grab him you might like
anything UCI rules get a comment he's
gonna eat a carrot like Peter Jackson in
The Hobbit and Lord of the Rings but um
know what Patrick Wilson is going to be
playing his form when she's basically
the low key of this University's he's
Aquaman's half brother and he's very
jealous of him because orman he wants to
rule society more and you know aqua
meant more like Thor worries more the
peaceful side so and their mother
obviously trusts Aquaman more so I'm
theory this is a really interesting move
because i really like Patrick Wilson
line it's funny little backup
Wilson is actually the voice of the
President of the United States and
Batman V Superman when they're saying to
nuke Superman and doomsday so so arm is
really the president that's right when
disguise so they're gonna have to
explain that Bruce Willis was dead the
whole time that's [ __ ] crazy in
copper yeah I think I mean I can't oh I
know Patrick Wilson splayed villains
before I can't quite room at all the a
team for the league is the villain a
team that's right I love that man here
everybody says i love for the longest
time I dude Patrick Wilson is a man who
always gets half naked or fully natured
it's gonna be underwater every movie he
does he's either sure this night o night
o is butt naked eye as you cease but
first movie I saw me was the miniseries
angels in america where he has sex with
a lady the chick from weeds was her name
mary-louise Parker yes and he has sex
with akiza's is the actual yeah what am
I always end up UT and yeah I I think
that's really cool i feel like James
Wan's gonna [ __ ] do a great job with
this movie she owns a guy like if James
Wan can't make a good movie out of this
I i will know as like James Wan can make
a solid movie just about anywhere he
seems like a guy who's really good and
making the movie he wants but still
playing with the team you know yes very
true very true all right John Stephanie
how remember Daniel DS question
Stephanie I'll ask what's your favorite
horror movie all right Andrew you go
first John I've answered this question
before I probably say I'm not the
biggest for fan but i'd probably say
nightmare on elm street
or I'm I delivery but in 1984 that movie
just like I can rewatch that moving
still get scared by it obviously there's
some 80 strokes in there that you see
when you see some of this the CGI
working and how afraid works but it
works in that movie like you were really
scared of that character it and like a
character who can attack you in your
nightmare it's just very very scary so
I've always an Robert Englund is Freddy
Krueger he's amazing yes he is yes he is
I tend to say my favorite movie screen I
later saw was some more movies I've
watched it really do make an impact on
me scream is the one that is I feel has
always been the that's a movie that's
like a love letter to war movies at the
same time being its own unique horror
movie and I know that like one of the
wasn't there a nightmare on elm street
that Wes Craven did word it was like the
actors yeah wes craven's new nightmare
yeah yeah that was kind of like the
playground for what kind of became
scream later and I feel like screaming i
I don't I just I talk about a lot on
this channel I just feel like scream
it's perfect I think it's a perfect
perfect when I fell in love with Neve
Campbell when I was young you know drew
Barrymore was supposed to play the role
[ __ ] that I'm glad she got killed the
first five minutes have a [ __ ]
deserved it favorite or me is hard CC
Texas chance of massacres wanted it I
think it's like a perfect it might be a
perfect film to me figure horror movies
always really tough question it changes
by the day I've said this a million
times and Ed Wood is my favorite movie
and it's like it's got horror stuff in
it but I wouldn't necessarily call like
a straight-up horror films we don't say
aliens is more sad if I didn't horn yeah
yeah we're gonna say or is a Lena I
think it's just a ruler yeah yeah I
think that's because like thriller off
of this like there's a weird debate you
can have about the word thriller because
a lot of people will say you know like
we're we're forced to kind of have the
argument over horror as a quality genre
and you come from from my side of the
tracks yeah so a lot of times people
will the people will love like respond
or movies in as thrillers and not for
and so it's hard to tell the room to
station is now like
look Lily between a thriller and horn
but I think they thrilled yes aliens is
a great example of a thrill like yeah
yeah aliens is like the sci fi thriller
alien vs predators like the whole to in
horton okay now d varies a horde about
that movie on my shelf I wouldn't say
it's a horror movie got made everybody
be have a very high rated but yeah I
don't know i mean the first alien is
very slow sonic that that is a lot of
warm elements to the first alien such a
bus such a claustrophobic film hey guys
you now has given us tips to get
incentives on how to get more bars i'm
totally ignoring all their tips i am i'm
just gonna tell you straight up John um
he really needs to buy some merchandise
for his mother and he needs some bars so
if you guys can donate some bars to help
John get specific horse merchandise for
his mother know what this is odd it is
like a kind of real how do people get
bars on YouTube exactly what everyone
YouTube saying thank you don't ever get
to Danielle's question if you really
make casts Chris Pratt might leave the
new console sorry I swear people in
YouTube say oh I you two people let's go
back to you for a second the room what's
your favorite jake gyllenhaal movie
prozac prisoners night crow I'd say
performances night all [ __ ] thought
Nightcrawler his performance and that
that's one of those few roles where I've
seen a film like Heath letter in the
dark night when you watch that
performance I don't see Heath Ledger at
all in the film when I watched night
crawler and I CJ and I watch jake
gyllenhaal like I really don't see Jake
Gyllenhaal's to this characters up but
if you pay attention about city slickers
one he was really good as Billy
Crystal's look at his face though yeah
no that's actually a hard question
because the thing is i would probably
prince of persia yes absolutely very
underrated movie uh no i would probably
rewatch Nightcrawler more time
but his role in prisoners is like one of
my favorite performances ever oh come
the comments got a little scattered
there I but someone wanted to know who
we cast this question from YouTube who
would we cast as Catwoman who we cast as
poison ivy I think Catwoman clearly
Halle Berry mmm and poison ivy who's
that girl from kill bill Oh Zoey Dale oh
no no no no uma thurman uma Thurman
attics boom with the remote vehicle
poison I'm surprised ya got any offer
yet over st. boys a knife yeah that's
who we are honestly I'm not going to
speculate who I want to play the role
just as long as they get I mean so far
the two actresses that they've had in
the more recent Catwoman versions or not
recent Halle Berry I mean the 92 film
batman returns I love Michelle
Pfeiffer's Catwoman I thought shelf lon
sorry Michelle Kwan I also enjoyed Anne
Hathaway's chem so I mean if they want
to go back to Halle Berry fine I'll
support that decision I guess but I mean
honestly at this point I don't want to
speculate who I think they should do it
I will see who the decision is and you
know we'll go from there but I just want
to see an actress who's really gonna
like feel like there is gonna portray
this role at to the right way because I
don't want that I don't want like you
said the Halle Berry version like that
was just crap yeah I think you guys are
too hard on a lot of very underrated
movie all right the shell Julia doesn't
am stone I think someone on you now for
emma stone is wouldn't mind that ah i
get i get why it would happen but I
actually don't yeah I wouldn't mind I
wouldn't my team liquid real seems like
an obvious choice for poison ivy but I
still would Alan good XO wouldn't mind
her I feel like she would be great cuz
Eva Green is great at playing seductive
villains that's very much a poison i yes
to be moes death and who else is there I
mean if you're getting Will Smith is
dead shot [ __ ] be in the Olympics
deeply worried it actually fits when you
see a comment with hair green this is a
perfect match or poison ivy the gina
carano complain
our cat woman I want her to be some good
chemistry as well with Batman down the
road ok so I'm think me SIA so Jennifer
Garner okay hahahaha jokes I mean I
precal would I want to play Catwoman a
real cat comfort is not taught copper um
yeah who would have want to play
Catwoman does it have to be someone
famous Sandra Dakota Fanning no please
has to be someone sexy and alluring
keira knightley nah she needs a bigger
bust I would love to see if Christina
Hendricks poison ivy but that's just
that's just for my own you know enjoy
yeah we'll keep it there i'd be down I'd
be done for Kate Beckinsale's got 1 i'll
ask whether it is don't want me to bring
them out and I could psychics yours
Kalin hey Daniel D said christina
hendricks her poison ivy then Brooke
like right around the time you said mila
kunis is Catwoman Christopher anyone
come on no no no I mean who's on TV
that's great i love it when they did
like a TV actor Evan realest very soul
um who's on Game of Thrones right now
who's still alive and should i have no
idea or you I don't know I can't fix
onca I can't think it would be a great
Catwoman can I know I know there's an
actress there's an actress get one of
the British actresses who's on the scene
yeah i was thinking British that's why I
thought keira knightley at first um yeah
I have I having a closer one getting
oscar-nominated who's going to get to
this opportunity oh I'll be Larson knob
real ours ruth negga can do it she could
Alicia vikander because Alicia vikander
would actually be a good choice Alicia
mechana is a good good choice and i
really really love i'm sure i've really
enjoyed her and everything I'm secret
but she's got that same right now this
is the same reason why I going back
somebody else a question why I'm
decided of the rear the rumor that Chris
Pratt will be solo and yet and already
cast on John I don't want to see this
person as everybody you can't or don't
want to sink her okay baby had a great 0
to 10 you can you be a great word to big
gray cat one I think tanning or Ruth
would because if you think back to
preacher like ruth negga had that
alluring thing she can also be tough as
nails and she's got that like sly or two
or Helen Mirren get [ __ ] great oh my
god if you gender met Alfred oh he's so
excited because no one will be a
beautiful nanny like everyone can agree
upon two women in this world and that's
Betty White or I'm used to be I should I
say Helen Mirren and Helen oh yeah I can
see Helen Mirren totally you know
nothing done so much freeze all of it
hey what was daniel DS question earlier
uh which friend stopped right Daniel
yeah remind us important but i believe
it was i thought was one that wouldn't
year one you wanted to continue how
about we dip oh ok a french and danielle
de ask which franchise we think could
have continued but what stopped ya um I
have to go back a half the mean as
excited as I am for the MCU I have to go
back to Sam Raimi's 50 I was gonna be
yours yeah Sam Raimi's spider-man is the
one franchise raava's light you mother
[ __ ] definitely ended his franchise
and is rebooted because I I'm really
excited for spider-man to be in the MCU
I really do love Tom Holland and civil
war i love the trailer but damn i like
they were working on it they were
working at a script ready they were
gonna do a four and five and it really
does bum me out because spider-man 3
didn't have to be the end note on that
franchise I feel like he could have gone
out strong I feel like if we learn from
whatever mistakes part 3 had lots of
mistakes well well it's a very
underrated movie well then but this the
thing about spider-man trees experiment
3 is is not a solid movie but it's one
of those movies where there are nuggets
of
and it does feel like a real movie the
way stuff especially superhero stuff it
doesn't feel that same way like there's
a different mold now but it only is a
bloated mess it is bloated mess but it
is it still has some of the earmarks and
some of the genuine heart that comes
with a sam raimi picture like it's still
as far as Sam Raimi blockbusters go I
still think more fondly on spider-man 3
than I do on it's like I don't even
really remember oz or some of those I
like spider-man 3 more than amazing
spider-man 2 exactly yeah and and I like
to move song peril [ __ ] the [ __ ] i like
to use talking about with the villains
and i really really want to see Dylan
Baker through the lizard and spectra
could have said no I'm eyes you
spider-man from life I love that
sequence out what about you what
franchise would you have liked to have
seen continued I I still gotta think a
little more and continue but franchise I
was happy to see stop was amazing
spider-man after amazing spider-man 2
and obviously when they got together to
reunite or rather bring the character
under the Marvel Cinematic Universe I
was hot very happy about that so I mean
amazing spider-man 2 that film just what
can you say about that film it's a very
big pile of steaming [ __ ] yes that's how
I really feel about it I I can't even
revisit it yeah I to who there is
there's this tube there's just too many
decimal there's just too many too many
things going on too many cooks in the
kitchen with that film and you get so
many different storylines are trying to
pander to the Sinister Six I can't even
focus on what they're trying doing Jamie
Foxx's character of electrodes just
ridiculous that characters in a
different version of that movie like
that he felt like Maura Sam Raimi's
spider-man villain done an amazing
spider-man though because you like wacky
and kind of whimsical that seems to be
the one thing I liked about the movie
movie bikes oh [ __ ] and I'll say
something a little controversial I guess
for serious i would have liked to
continue you know i do love the
daredevil Marvel TVs universe we're
gonna say 12 years a slave i will say if
you watch the daredevil director's cut
with ben affleck I really freaking think
that movies really underrated the
director's cut not
a triple cut that movie sucks now that
I'm really weary watch the directors cut
it's actually a pretty good movie they
add 30 minutes and there's more there's
more scenes going on there's more
storyline especially with Matt Murdock
as a lawyer you get a different side of
Ben Affleck and then it's doing work
better things at Matt back also too I
really think if that version would have
been released that would have spawned uh
more sequels for that franchise and
again the theatrical version hell no
that movie sucks the director's cut that
deserves a sequin I mean I would have
been down for that the somebody shout
out the 28 movies you mean like 28 days
later 28 weeks later because that's that
would be cool to know she's talking
about 28 days oh yeah rehab she goes
through a different thing to rehab
actually I'll do you one because we had
the same one I really wished and this is
the last time I at least recall really
hoping for a sequel was the 81 I love
the 18-man I don't give [ __ ] I know
nobody else likes it got a 50-percent
than 50-percent like when something
falls there on rotten tomatoes I'm
usually like that's one of those movies
where if you don't like it you don't
like it do like it you do and I had a
great time with that movie and I was
really bummed that a sequel did not get
me whoa Alice rocks just donated four
thousand bars Thank You Alice rocks I am
in shocks you're gonna get some
Christmas stocks Reginald beans and as
you have unwise this rock of a wall like
static shock dude this is it is are they
making a static shock movie I thought I
heard like a rumor yeah um its stars
Tyrese Gibson it's a really old high
school or good hey Christine love the 18
tutor not alone John yes to not alone
someone in the internet who might see
the two fans of the 18 MDS filmer on
youtube because we can't just real fast
hey night o night miss just talked Alice
night missed with the bars miss dry milk
and Alice
oh my god night miss and Alex rocks that
could be the new versus movie of who
could donate the most bars to the real
region X in the matter of a broadcast
thank you for becoming a fan Christopher
me dude 9s and alex rox hayleybay loves
dating to I feel like there's a word for
penis that rhymes with rock um oh no
wait what claw jock yeah I have a huge
[ __ ] for you Alice rotting then night
missed you deserve a kiss it's called
forcing rhymes bubble bum boy 2 is my
favorite Jake Jonah hey hey hey wait was
a question any swimmer asked on youtube
are you excited for the punisher Netflix
show yeah I i haven't been this excited
for a Punisher thing in a long time like
the vet I remember what I found out that
jumper Thal was cast as the Punisher
that was one of those choices where
you're like perfect perfect choice and
then right when it comes out on
daredevil everyone's like perfect that's
the best way to describe jon bernthal
the Punisher and the Netflix shows I
find incredibly more engaging and
extremely more memorable than any of the
movies so seeing jon bernthal unlike I'm
cuz that's a real antihero ownership so
it's not like Luke Cage daredevil even
Jessica Jones to a certain extent
they're very good protagonists are good
heroes but like while they're
contemplated it either in our complex
and [ __ ] Punisher is
at all
I mean they sent him up is like the
penisy like I imagine that will be their
most violent show yeah no I mean he's
such a sympathetic character too so like
I mean I'm really looking forward to
this to that action that we got to see
in the daredevil by punishment he's just
killing people left and right it was
just so much so much fun and mayhem to
watch so I'm and jon bernthal he just
really embodies the role of Frank Castle
I mean that one scene where he's talking
to Matt Murdock by the graveyard late I
mean I was a bit i was in tears in that
scene like so he really like i said he
bodies the role and i'm really excited
for this series and like he said we've
got a lot of heroes in this marbled a
television cinematic universe that we
got now so it's gonna be cool to see
like an antihero and steve and seeing
someone's just gonna kill people left
and right so you know i'm really excited
for the defender show yeah because I
mean I know we haven't seen iron fist
yet I have no doubt it's going to be
just as great as the other shows because
that because I'm more excited for the
defenders and I am for infinity war
honestly because infinity war while it's
going to be crazy fun excitement don't
get me wrong I'm excited for that but
the defenders I'm like whoa you got like
three amazing shows I've seen so far
that are three out of oven I've seen
iron fist yes it's gonna be like four
shows crossing over now it's up I'm so
mad because we're gonna get time to hang
out with these guys it's not going to be
just a two-hour episode it's gonna be
it's going to be a lot of death
13-episode yeah it's gonna be a lot and
it's a time where we gonna get the
chance to see a ultimate crossover where
you really do get to explore all these
characters throughout the season that
that one I get her really sure he's
playing the villain with actress no
Sigourney Weaver oh yeah I did hear
about that yeah yeah that's right of
reprising her role from Le Paul she's
not playing on rippling no she's the
villain that she wasn't Paul I never saw
Paul's at the movie with Simon what are
with that Seth Rogen yeah yes and Simon
Baker well about getting my movie facts
all the Sun all right guys we're gonna
wrap this up really soon we'll just
answer a couple more
questions and then we really call it a
night thank you guys for everyone who's
been on this chat so i guess i'm not
gonna live for almost an hour ok ok
let's look at a couple more questions
going through you too let's go through
the youtube / feel it's like a YouTube
question that are you now question no no
no no no no no I'll take that one
Bernard five four three step brothers 20
so you're talking about college books in
turbulence talking about conflicts in
this in this section a step brothers too
I mean I heard that they're coming back
together for sherlock holmes movie yeah
and they've been talking about making
that movie for a few years now actually
because i think they originally
announced that they were doing the will
ferrell sacha baron cohen was attached
the time like what are they good right
no no but this I think this is around
the time of either like the show or the
guy ritchie movies or something like
they've been talking about doing that
for a long time and i have not heard
anything about it while I didn't notice
still thing I think step brothers to be
awesome yeah I think I think it would be
because i don't i don't see them it's
just recycling you know that's what I
gotta say about anchorman 2 huh even
though i don't really like anchorman 2 I
don't feel the problem is because of
recycled material you know I don't feel
it's because of recycled jokes I still
feel like they still tried doing new
things which doesn't make me like so I'm
not saying that the aid my support for a
step brother Steve but I'd be like a
step brothers 2 is the thing a lot of
people have really wanted and i think
john c reilly will ferrell are thee like
i would hate it if they did like a dumb
and dumber herb with step brothers you
know but who would you cast go ok tom
holland and robert downey jr and robert
downey jr
brothers too I can't want to see the
stepper brothers oh you know what man I
think it's Deb brothers two could work
in theory because the thing about step
brothers like I know increment oh whoa
Christian Manzanero donated 10,000 bucks
oh you guys are so cried at the end of
the video this is for you Christian
thank you so much look at this touch it
John yeah every time he touches did I do
that touch it again job here's Chi good
your shoutout Christian haha sku my
shirt off for Christians Otis is done
but the thing about step where this is
like the first one is such a loose movie
and it's it's kind of over long and it's
like it's so crazy and like how
committed they are to to what the joke
is so like at least for me I kind of got
to admire that movie even when it's not
working because it is so sure of what
it's doing and I feel like there is
something about that little piece of
magic where they could come up with a
wacky drum as a new stuff ya know I love
step brothers it's like it's one of my
favorite comedies ever and my only my
only thing I'm a little worried about is
how many comedies rules can you name
that are grabbing at wayne's world 2 but
how many on the top your head comedy
sequels can you name that are really
funny and as good as the first tell me
run over to rush hour 2 I actually like
okay like nights is funny I'll check
your hands sequels of fun christopher 81
this is not embarrassing what I'm doing
Christian donated Christian you are
spoiling me my dear you're spoiling us
through so it now night is oh my god you
guys are so I'm taking off my pants
right now and you can't even tell but
I'm completely but naked for you can you
talk about alien covenant
that'll be the last question for the
night Gonzaga closely we've talked about
alien covenant yeah okay okay I got a
quick one jiten Jimmy Neutron devil Oh
set where where we'll marvel go after
the affinity of war films they lend
Marvel will shut down as a studio
they'll kill off all their heroes that's
my prediction I would love it I would
love it if marble like like let's say
like 10 20 years from now if not 10
nobody many years from now they just
started tanking horribly they're like
[ __ ] it let's just do Punisher kills the
marvel universe I think that would be so
[ __ ] sweet if they did that food wait
weekend on that okay well what do you
wear my shirt Robin do you think would
best describe yourself what DC Marvel
superhero or villain by Stephanie she
asked we best describe yourself um I'm a
little bit more like a UH like like a
low key you know my like low key because
i like the Frostbite [ __ ] butter that
beasts oh no who after you go for a
sorority their minds August come on man
like the shirt and yours totally Batman
weapon but who is most like you now
Bruce Wayne I'm a billionaire
billionaire philanthropist play why do
you think he doesn't work on really
trying to promote his channel he doesn't
need the chain by midnight man Jesus
John John is uh who does dave bautista
play Oh didn't I tries dress Russell
when you're too logical about it I get
you were dragged scutum partner
Christopher anyone says I'm like a
rocket raccoon I can see that I don't
know where you get that makes me crude
and I've always been group
we pick so can't be a veces Andrew Bruce
Wayne Greg Tony Stark John Oliver Queen
sean is Oliver Queen what oh that's a
compliment really how I wanna be queen
is why you suck o Queen is like super
sexy he's like he's like Batman but for
Starling city in some ways oh wow thank
you say you're doing here too it's not
the worst life man nah hey that's that's
all that's all billionaires in this
scenario that's trip I mean he'll think
that's this point actually um yes all
right guys we're gonna call this night
we want to keep it to like an hour today
thank you to everyone who tuned in how
do you donate bars [ __ ] somebody says uh
you go on you now and you got Adams
you're the last shout out mr. Adams
thank you all for tuning in you can
subscribe to Andrews movie source
channel movie talks about movies he's a
source for that John is the social media
manager of facebook.com slash bloom
house or blue house com also the social
media manager of the Facebook of the
real rejects I'm Greg album I am the
third Schmo so in true vs grizzlies make
sure to subscribe to Collider videos
thank you guys you all have a great
night and special shout out so the guys
who donated bars will start from least
bars to most violent it's about
competition pull up down your pan alley
Oh down your pants thank you so much Joe
Brown oh my god you clown alex rox my
kasra night mist has brought me bliss
Christian man's and NATO makes me go
home oh oh we are bars you Christian are
the real Christian you are the Jesus to
my Christ we're gonna add on that now
Thank You Christian and thank you for
all the likes to everyone cheers y'all
way to come to us we clearly work hard
for it oh I had this vodka
thing oh oh yeah my bad John go end it
yeah seeing behind the scenes dubai
everyone on YouTube good bye YouTube
goodbye now and are you sure